Mi-na, can you do me a big favor?
Can I borrow some money?
I have to pay off my credit card by next week, and I don't have enough to do that.
At this rate, I will soon become a credit delinquent.
I heard when a recruiting agency or a big - named company tries to hire you,...
...they look up your credit history and decide whether to hire you or not.
This is my first time sitting on such debt.
Could you help me out please?
How much do you owe the credit company?
Where did you spend all the money?
Let me have it.
You should at least make a minimum payment.
I also heard about an employer checking your bank account.
You should be careful about that.
I think it's more serious than we think.
As consumer spending is holding steady,...
...we see the rising level of debt people are putting on credit cards,...
...and quite a few of them are concerned about being able to pay it off.
As more consumers fall behind on credit payments,...
...there are increasing activities of so-called debt counselors or debt settlement services.
Anyways, I guess there should be new laws regarding debt settlement,...
...relieving debts of credit delinquents.
That's a good idea.
We should not just wait for them to pay back their debts,...
...but need to find some ways to solve this problem.
But the problem is, still, there are some debates going on to decide whether to help them or not.
The problem of credit delinquency is getting serious in many countries.
It is one of the big social issues.